chasing money the struggle is guaranteed
the success is not i thought that my
primary driver was getting wealthy and i
realize now that it's not and my primary
driver is fulfillment and chasing money
does not fulfill me i think that
everything in life comes down to what
your own value system is so what's your
identity what are your beliefs what are
your values what are your habits what
are your routines if you just gave me a
sheet that told me what those were about
somebody i would tell you what the
outcome of their life is going to be
when i was growing up part of the reason
i wanted to get rich was i looked at
those people with admiration and i did
not look at myself with admiration so i
thought oh well if i can get wealthy
then i will look at myself with
admiration this would be amazing and
then when i got the money by then i had
changed myself fundamentally as a person
and i had earned so much self-respect
and so much self-worth that by the time
i got the money i didn't i wasn't
looking for anything from the money
other than it is the great facilitator
it will let you do extraordinary things
but it won't make you an extraordinary
person it won't make you feel any
differently about yourself and because
the money came literally like that
because we had paper wealth so i was a
worth hundreds of millions of dollars on
paper but i just cannot stress enough
that's meaningless in your real life i
was driving you know at one point a beat
up ford focus my wife and i had to share
it had a leaky exhaust and yet i'm worth
at that point i was worth tens of
millions of dollars but there were
employees that were living far better
lives than i was from a financial
standpoint so that's paper money now
bank account money came in an instant
and so it was about i don't know six
years into our journey and we um decided
to take a small investment to diversify
so it was a pure founder liquidity
moment and because the valuation of the
company was over a billion dollars you
can imagine even at a small percentage
just the raw number of dollars is
insanity so
all of a sudden i was fantastically
wealthy it is so in fact this this was
how that day went so
everyone i said earlier you beliefs
values identity habits routines right
these are the things that make people up
and i just have a value system that says
it's not about the money it's about
building something you believe in it's
about serving other people it's about
work ethic it's about showing up and
working and i value myself for that so
on the day that the money hit it hit it
like i don't know 8 am in the morning or
something
and my wife we're both in the gym
and she's like what are we gonna do
today and i was like what do you mean
i'm going to work
and she like couldn't wrap her head
around that huh she's like what we're
going to go to the lamborghini dealer
yeah she's like come on we've got to
like go do something we've got to
celebrate and i'm like there's no
universe in which i don't show up for
work today none under no circumstances
so if you were to ask my employees when
did the money hit they'll be like i have
no idea they knew that it did hit but
they didn't know what day because i
acted completely the same and the thing
that i want people to understand is i
feel the same so all of the like things
that i believe about myself to be good i
still believe to be good i earned them i
earned them by doing the hard thing time
and time and time and time again i think
that everything in life comes down to
what your own value system is so what's
your identity what are your beliefs what
are your values what are your habits
what are your routines when you figure
those out that like if you just gave me
a sheet that told me what those were
about somebody i would tell you what the
outcome of their life is going to be and
for me implementation being willing to
face the fears the anxieties the unknown
the need to stare at my inadequacy so i
can figure out what skills i actually
need in order to go and do something
because implementation is really a
question of skill set that's why
motivation ultimately is going to let
you down it's like you may be motivated
to go do something but let me walk you
through exactly what will happen you're
motivated to try this thing which you
don't know how to do and you suck at it
and so you go do that thing you suck it
hurts your ego because your ego is tied
up in being right being good being
talented worthy all those like permanent
um
set states that people don't realize are
malleable and so they get stuck in that
it damages their self-esteem so they
want to run in the opposite direction
psychological immune system kicks in
reminds them that that was stupid anyway
why were they worried about even trying
that and so they back off and any one
time doing that's not a big deal it's
just that people do that over and over
and over and over and over what do you
have to do to counteract that and the
thing you have to do is emotionally
reward yourself for being willing to
take the steps so okay i know i'm gonna
do this i'm gonna suck at it it's gonna
hurt it's gonna hurt my self-esteem and
so what do i need to do to make sure
that i don't trip up over that in a way
that makes me turn and run in the
opposite direction number one stop
valuing myself for being good at
something and start valuing myself for
being willing to learn so when i see
something that i want to accomplish
then i know that i'm going to have the
fortitude and the stamina to see that
through because it taps into my identity
of the learner and my value system of
this is important and should be done so
then i just keep going down so i hit the
wall of my inadequacy and i don't meet
that with stopping i meet that with cool
now i know what i have to get better at
i'm now aware of what the skill set is
and so now that i know what skill set i
need to develop and i believe that it
can be developed then i just put the
work into developing the skill so when
it came to do i buy an island and retire
or do i double down it came down to what
will make me
love my life the most and the reality is
the thing that would make me love my
life the most because it would still be
fun to just go home be with my wife but
the thing that'll make me love my life
the most is to do the things that are
fulfilling and i think fulfillment has a
very specific universal formula and that
formula is
work your ass off to get very good at
something that you care deeply about
that allows you to serve not only
yourself but other people what do i want
to do what do i want to give what do i
want to create when you look at skills
from that perspective it is like being a
superhero it is being a superhero you're
going to collect these abilities these
abilities actually let you do something
the fact that superman can fly allows
him to save people allows him to do
things other people can't do we all have
this opportunity to become capable of
the extraordinary to be able to do
things other people can't do and that
feels so good they say
a fool never learns a smart man learns
from his mistakes and a wise man learns
from the mistakes of others far too
often i've been a fool and have repeated
mistakes over and over and over and but
i really do try to be smart i'm not
usually as wise as i would like to be
and just find that i um i learn things
the hard way but i really do learn them
so
pain for me is a tremendous instructor
maybe because i hate it so much and just
want to move away from it but thankfully
i don't run from it i figure out what i
did that made me feel that pain whether
it's what i value myself for or whether
it's just hey bad skill set you need to
address it and then actually addressing
it so in the time where i was chasing
money first three years gave to me and
then the next three years chipped away
at my
my ability to enjoy my life at the end
of that i had spent about three and a
half years being profoundly unhappy
profoundly where it's like it was
hurting my marriage my wife would want
to talk about work and i wouldn't want
to talk about it i would get this like
sense of dread as i approached the
office it was just gnarly man and it was
in that period that i developed really
crushing anxiety because a i was always
in over my head because i didn't know
anything about business and it was just
really hard to learn i was in a very
intense um environment where it's just
like you'd hear things like only an
idiot would do that like all day every
day i feel like oh my god this is
exhausting and so you put that all
together and i'm doing all of that for a
product i don't believe in i'm not
building community i'm not connected to
people like community all that stuff
none of it existed so i was just like i
am so unhappy and somebody wrote an
article unfortunately i only read the
headline but i i so know the feeling
that it resonated and it was the joy of
quitting and there's that moment when
you first quit and it's like
the lift the burden lifted off you is so
profound because that that particular
frame of reference is just in an instant
it's gone and that's amazing and that's
what i was thinking about when i went in
and quit i was like i just need the
change of circumstance badly and so
my solution was going to be to go do the
only thing that ever made me feel
awesome and that is creating film so
and i didn't have the finances to make
like actual films but i could write them
which is essentially just your time and
i remember there was a time before i
quit where i had directed a feature film
and i direct this feature film over a
few weekends and then i edit it myself
nights and weekends and i was so excited
to do that that i was sleeping between
45 minutes and two hours a night without
setting an alarm for like 10 days and i
thought this is inhuman how is it
possible i'm waking up with this little
sleep and it was because i was so
excited i wanted to like get this film
done and show it to everybody and the
actual act of cutting it together which
for anybody who messes with film here
off camera they know it is so fun when
you see it like come together and you're
creating this moment you feel something
and you give yourself the chills it's
like that for me makes me feel alive i
was like i want to feel like that
all the time
so that was all i knew i was no smarter
than that i just knew feeling dead
inside
hating my life hating my job was so
miserable i'd rather be poor doing
something that i loved than rich doing
something that i hated